mon chaton sera vis de vous retrouver
pour cette nouvelle édition de senna à
360 voici lé petit train les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement parmi les
thèmes le référendum l'idée fait son
chemin et pourrait venir conclure le
grand débat autres interpellations des
sénateurs les perquisitions chez
mediapart dans la sphère benalla la
science est à suivre sur notre antenne
dans 15 minutes
quelle mobilisation pour la grève
générale pour la première fois la cgt
les gilet jaune manifestants semblent un
peu partout en france
jusqu'ici la convergence des luttes n'a
pas pris
nous serons en direct du cortège
parisien dans un instant zone de
turbulences en vue au sénat sur la
privatisation des aéroports de paris à
l'occasion de l'examen de la loi pacte
les sénateurs aient l'air vont s'unir
avec la gauche pour dire non à la
cession d'actifs voulu par le
gouvernement
le débat s'annonce houleux le détail
dans cette émission et je vous rappelle
que vous pouvez réagir sur twitter avec
le hashtag ses mains à 360 pour
m'accompagner
cet après midi on retrouvera jérôme
ravier en direct et des manifestations à
paris et puis van tran huy et alexandre
pissas au sénat le multiplex cette suite
c'est donc une première cgt et gilet
jaune main dans la main dans la rue
alors faut-il y voir un début de
convergence la centrale organise une
grève nationale de 24 heures pour
réclamer aux salaires et justice fiscale
avec à ses côtés des gilets jaunes on va
d'ailleurs retrouver sur place je rentre
à pied avec jonathan du prez
oui des fines et après 12 samedi de
mobilisation des gilets jaunes c'est le
retour de la manifestation en semaine
d'abord où la aidiez à l'appel de la cgt
la centrale de montreuil qui refuse de
participer au grand débat national et
veut montrer dans la rue son opposition
à la politique d' emmanuel macron les
gilets rouges de la cgt qui ont su
fédérer avec la présence d'autres
syndicats comme solidaires mais aussi
deux partis de gauche et de gilet jaune
pour le secrétaire général philippe
martinez c'est le grand début de la
convergence sont l'écoutent
on a les mêmes intérêts quand je vois
des slogans hausse du smic justice
fiscale baisse de la tva sur les
ronds-points plus de service public
c'est dès ce moment qu'on crée depuis
maintenant fort longtemps et donc quand
on est rassemblé d'ailleurs les gilets
jaunes ont re découvert l'action
collective
quand on met rassembler on est toujours
plus efficace que quand on est divisé
c'est aussi valable pour les syndicates
d'ailleurs alors si le cortège de la cgt
a été le plus garni on a pu voir des
politiques du parti communiste de la
france insoumise deux générations ou
encore du mouvement place publique les
gilet jaune était aussi très présent en
tête et en queue de cortège et que ce
soit du côté des gilet jaune comme des
représentants des partis on salue cette
nouvelle étape dans la mobilisation
merci beaucoup aux gens mais pour toutes
ces précisions
au moins dix morts et 37 blessés dans
l'incendié d'un immeuble à paris le
drame s'est produit en pleine nuit dans
le 16ème arrondissement de la capitale
il a fallu plus de cinq heures aux
pompiers pour maîtriser le feu il s'agit
de l'incendié le plus meurtrier à paris
depuis près de 14 ans la piste
criminelle est privilégiée
une habitante de l'immeuble a été placé
en garde à vue pour destructions
volontaires ayant entraîné la mort après
ce violent incendie
on va d'ailleurs retrouver tam trains de
nuit en direct de la salle des
conférences du sénat pour une réaction à
ce qu'un cent dix qui est donc a fait 10
morts avec vous la sénatrice l air de
paris à céline boulay sperone yettaw oui
ces lignes vous l'espériez nous allons
parler ensemble de ce drame qui s'est
déroulé cette nuit rue erlanger dans le
16e arrondissement de paris l'heure est
pour l'instant à l'émotion mais aussi
bien à l'hommage au travail des pompiers
bien sûr à l'hommage au travail des
pompiers remerciant les 250 pompiers qui
ont un vrai pendant cinq ou six heures
cette nuit pour éteindre un incendie qui
s'est déclaré avant une heure du matin
d'une ampleur absolument considérable
est affolante mois le même je me suis
rendu sur place dès 7 heures ce matin et
j'ai pu constater l'étendue des dégâts
alors comme vous le dites nous penser
toutes nos pensées vraiment notre
tristesse va vers les victimes et vers
les familles des victimes
l'heure est au bilan il est de dix morts
bilan hélas hélas et on espère qu'un
bilan provisoire vise la voie là
puisqu'il va falloir 24 heures encore
aux policiers pour établir un bilan
définitif aller jusque dans les derniers
étages pour voir s'il n'y a pas de
l'équipe supplémentaires une enquête est
en cours pour l'instant la piste
criminelle est privilégiée votre
commentaire là dessus on a aussi pu
entendre et bien le ministre jean
normandie de dire qu'il n'y avait pas
d'un salubrité dans cet immeuble il n'y
avait pas d'insalubrité c'était un
immeuble elle a ses petits de 8 étages
d'où la difficulté des pompiers avec cd
évidemment c'était un immeuble dans une
petite cour avec des ailes de surcroît
donc ce qui fait que le camion de
pompier n'a pas pu accéder qu'ils ont
été utilisées des aides et des échelles
très étroite pour évacuer les gens et
ils ont évacué enfin ils ont ils
auraient pu y avoir bien au contraire
laurent 40 ou 50 morts de plus oui alors
hommage leur soit rendue vraiment
vraiment qu'est ce que met en place et
bien le 16e arrondissement de paris à
une cellule d'accompagnement installé
dans la mairie de prévu tout à fait les
victimes les personnes qui doivent être
logés il y en a une quarantaine à peu
près sont accueillis à la mairie à
l'heure actuelle et depuis tôt ce matin
les relogements sont en cours il ya un
numéro vert aussi dont je vous redonne
le numéro parce que c'est utile pour les
personnes qui cherchent encore des
proches qui est le 0 805 400 250 et la
préfecture de police a mis en place une
cellule de crise et il faut évidemment
aussi des cellules psychologiques
notamment pour les colères langer qui
jouxte le lieu du héros il arrivera dans
les traumatiser bien sûr qu'elle fait
tout à fait et la piste criminelle est
évidemment privilégié puisque je crois
que c'est ce qui est à l'origine de ceux
de cet incendie dramatique c'est un
problème entre la joie là mais
évidemment la justice va suivre son
cours mais une dame de 40 ans a été
arrêté avec des problèmes psychologiques
des problèmes d'alcoolisme et là encore
une fois aujourd'hui l'heure alors nous
parlons l'heure est vraiment au
recueillement et de dire à quel point
les élus voilà son côté de sont aux
côtés des victimes bien entendu merci
beaucoup si l'une voulait se renier
d'avoir répondu à mes questions
merci merci à vous tendre pour cette
première réaction le gouvernement on va
devoir affronter un front insolite au
sénat sur le projet de privatisation des
aéroports de paris une majorité de
sénateurs les républicains y étant
opposés tout comme la gauche le débat
aura lieu en fin de journée dans
l'hémicycle et il s'annonce en flammes
et fabien à coeur c'est un front
insolite qu'affronte le gouvernement au
sénat la gauche est contre la
privatisation d'aéroports de paris et se
réjouit d'un allié de circonstance la
droite
comment
des gaullistes veulent privatiser
charles de gaulle c'est ça qui m'a bien
sûr son on avait déjà vu à l'assemblée
que beaucoup de police n'avaient pas
voté et au sénat on a le clan collins
qui se ressaisit c'est la majorité du
sénat et qui sont rejetés cette
privatisation en bloc et ils ont raison
une majorité de sénateurs et l'air
s'oppose en effet à la privatisation
mais ne veut pas pour autant parler
d'union sacrée avec le ps c'est pas la
guerre 14
mais ceci étant dit je pense qu'il y
aura une grande majorité effectivement
au sénat pour s'opposer à cette
privatisation
on est sur un sujet qui est un sujet
éminemment politique et pas simplement
un sujet financier
on a une philosophie globalement plutôt
libérale donc on est plutôt favorable
sur la logique de privatisation sauf que
ce n'est pas logique de privatiser un
monopole un monopole et surtout un actif
stratégique aux yeux dlr qui voit
pourtant leurs alliés centristes se
ranger sur la ligne du gouvernement
l'ancien maire du bourget vincent
capo-canellas se veut pragmatique quand
je vois certains à droite chez nos amis
à l'air qui s'aligne sur les positions
du parti socialiste je m'étonne et puis
je pense aussi que le gouvernement est
confronté c'est vrai à des difficultés
budgétaires que l'intérêt de l'état
c'est sans doute de procéder à des
cessions des centristes partisans
d'aménager le texte du gouvernement
une position minoritaire au sénat qui
restera opposé à la privatisation
emmanuel macron était hier à evry pour
la cinquième fois le chef de l'état a
rencontré des maires des élus mais aussi
des responsables associatifs pour tenter
de rouvrir avec les banlieues jusque là
tenus à l'écart du grand débat alors
s'il a répondu aux doléances il a
surtout dû justifier l'enterrement du
plan borloo
reportage sur place de contrats gagnés
certains retiennent la performance de ce
cinquième débat 6 heures à écouter et à
s'expliquer point par point pour les 300
maires et représentants du monde
associatif présent dans la salle
à evry courcouronnes emmanuel macron a
semblé être à l'écouté
c'est une étape réel me semble-t-il de
prise en considération
des élus locaux des associations des
conseillers citoyens logement formation
professionnelle accès aux services
publics
c'est parfois avec émotion que les élus
et associations de banlieue interpelle
le chef de l'état avec un message qui
revient à plusieurs reprises
il faut réparer l'ascenseur social et
lutter davantage contre les inégalités
en banlieue
nous sommes des villes qui sont
assoiffés d'égalité nous voulons
l'égalité républicaine
le chef de l'état qui esquisse un mea
culpa sur les emplois aidés supprimés au
début du quinquennat
puis propose de travailler sur les
emplois francs dans les associations
mais huit mois après l'enterrement du
plan borloo quels débouchés pour ce
grand débat dans les banlieues
effectivement le président de la
république ce soir à évoquer un certain
nombre de pistes pour améliorer le
fonctionnement des associations pour
continuer à favoriser la construction de
logements pour toujours lutté et sans
relâche contre cette discrimination qui
perdure dans notre pays
autant de nouvelles pistes qu'on va
continuer à travailler dans le cadre de
ce grand débat pour faire là aussi cet
acte 2 participé à cet acte ii du
quinquennat qui devra encore une fois
inclure l'ensemble de nos habitants dans
les quartiers
à l'issue de ces six heures élus
associations le promettent ils resteront
vigilants pour que toutes ces paroles se
transforment en actes et on continue à
les réactions avec vos attentes traduit
avec le sénateur socialiste martial
bourquin sur ce grand débat est aussi
sur la loi pintât et oui effectivement
martial bourquin tout d'abord que pensez
vous de la façon dont se déroule le
début de ce grand débat et notamment et
bien ces longues séances avec emmanuel
macro pour vous est-ce que hier le
président de la république est parvenue
à renouer avec les banlieues
déjà je fais la différence entre ce que
c'est qu'un débat est un monologue
j'ai l'impression que c'est très long
monologue
et que la parole n'est pas beaucoup
donné que les parterres sont choisis je
crois qu'il n'entrevoit pas question
tout de même lors de ces alors avec la
vielle puisque vous savez les élus sont
des élus républicains
les maires vont au-devant des autorités
lorsqu'ils sont sollicités mais quand
même aujourd'hui il y à un grand
mouvement soutenu par la majorité de la
population qui dit que le pouvoir
d'achat les institutions telle qu'elle
fonctionne pose problème est plutôt que
de monologuer en permanence
il vaudrait mieux aller vers ces
personnes avoir un vrai débat et
apporter de vraies réponses
j'ai l'impression que le compte n'y est
pas on fait un débat sur les banlieues
vous rendez compte l'humiliation de
monsieur borloo s'il ya quelques temps
qui a fait un bon rapport parce qu'il
faut le dire je peu près un an après ce
rapport qui a été un héros absolu jean
louis borloo absolument et vous ne
pensez pas qu un moment donné il faut
respecter le travail d'une personne
comme monsieur borloo qui a fait
beaucoup sur les sur les sites et sur
les quartiers difficiles qui a des idées
qui amenait en débat des questions
essentielles d'un revers de la main
balayés alors je sais pas ce que vont
donner ces débats on a l'impression que
le président joue avec ses performances
c'est pas ça qu'on attend massalbaye
burqa on va également dire un mot des
privatisations
ça va être l'un des temps forts du débat
sur le projet de loi impact ce soir vous
êtes opposés à ces privatisations
notamment à celle d' adp pour quelles
raisons
il ya eu la privatisation des autoroutes
on le sait est un désastre financier
je crois que les dividendes obtenues en
privatisant ont été aurait été payé deux
fois
vous avez perdu même scénario ce que
vous êtes bien sûr et puis surtout pas
des pc très différents c'est un monopole
d'état
on privatise une rente d'état il faut le
dire ces 117 milliards qui était qui et
qui que l'état avait régulièrement qui
va augmenter considérablement avec
l'augmentation du trafic voyageurs et
donc plus tard adp c'est une affaire
rentable on ne comprend pas pourquoi est
ce que on accéderait au privé alors est
ce que c'est une façon de remercier
vinci après la suppression de l'aéroport
de nantes je suis pas une des questions
en tout cas on ne privatise pas un
monopole d'état n'est pas sensible aux à
ce que dit le rapporteur qui propose des
garanties ou encore et bien le
gouvernement qui dit eh bien il faut
bien financer l'innovation de rupture
pour vous ne sont pas leurs arguments
l'innovation de rupture puisque on ne
fait pas seulement critiquer
l'innovation de rupture
qu'est ce qu'on veut faire une
innovation de rupture les simples
dividendes adp permettrait de contracter
un emprunt pour financer l'innovation de
rupture évidente de cette année mais il
ya pire ça pu être qu ils vont augmenter
selon les amis vont augmenter il
augmente régulièrement le titre adp je
le dire tout à l'heure augmente
régulièrement
c'est une entreprise florissante on
construit des aéroports dans le monde
entier
la à des pc l'ouverture de de la france
sur le monde et l'europe
quand on arrive aéroport charles de
gaulle quand on arrive à orly bourget eh
bien on arrive en france je crois que
c'est 90 % du fret passe par la ferrari
faire-part ferroviaire au niveau de
l'aviation et où vous rendez compte de
ce qu'on est en train de privatiser
alors il ya toulouse il ya le syndrome
de toulouse vous rendez compte ce qui
s'est passé la cour des comptes a été
très sévère dans un rapport d'octobre
2010 8 sur la ffh tivement
je pense qu'avec adp le gouvernement
s'apprête à faire pire qu'avec les
autoroutes s'apprête à faire pire
qu'avec toulouse et bien merci à
beaucoup martial bourquin d'avoir
répondu à merci à vous merci beaucoup
sam prendre à présent l'annexion de
l'hémicycle vous nous attendent et
alexandre pour sar quel est l'ordre du
jour de ces questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
il vient d'être fini on va parler du
grand débat national et de l'issue que
pourrait prendre toutes ces
consultations dans les territoires deux
questions de la droite et du centre vont
porter sur un éventuel référendum le 26
mai prochain le jour des élections
européennes c'est une piste à laquelle
réfléchit emmanuel macron pour sortir de
cette crise des gilet jaune
mais cette idée divisé jusque dans le
gouvernement puisque jean yves le drian
le ministre de l'europe et des affaires
étrangères a d'ailleurs estimé que ce
référendum n'était pas souhaitable car
l'enjeu des élections européennes
étaient suffisamment fort et en réalité
cette idée est soutenue par quelques
députés la république en marche et
notamment sacha oublier le député de la
vienne et qu'il ya des doutes sur la
possibilité logistique juridique
d'organiser un tel référendum dans des
délais aussi courts on sait que le grand
débat national fini à la mi avril
il s'agirait donc d'organiser ce
référendum
en un peu plus d'un mois ce qui paraît
assez compliqué et puis il ya tout un
débat sur le contenu de ce référendum
quelles questions vont être posées aux
français on sait que l'idée d'un
référendum déjà questions multiples
émergent
et puis que les questions ainsi su
institutionnels 1 pourrait prendre le
pas dans ce référendum notamment sur le
non-cumul des mandats sur la baisse du
nombre de parlementaires mais la gauche
estime qu'un référendum institutionnel
serait un écran de fumée pour cacher les
autres renwez revendications de ce grand
débat notamment sur la question du
pouvoir d'achat et sur la justice
fiscale on entend que la cloche sonne
c'est le début de ces questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
pressés à madame le maire de paris et à
madame le maire du xvième arrondissement
les pensées du sénat après le drame de
la rue erlanger jia ceci bien sûr tous
nos collègues parisiens dans ses pensées
que nous partageons monsieur le premier
ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues l'ordre du jour appelle
les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
je vous rappelle que la séance est
retransmis sur public sénat sur notre
site
et chacun sera attentif au respect du
temps mais pas qu'une litanie d'entrée
c'est à respecter tout au long de la
séance
ainsi que le respect des uns et des
autres et je donne la parole à notre
collègue joël guerriau pour le groupe
les indépendants république et
territoires
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre que vous savez les etats-unis
ont décidé vendredi dernier de suspendre
leur participation au traité sur les
forces nucléaires de portée
intermédiaire et justifient leur
position du fait que les russes seraient
sur le point de mettre en place de
nouveaux missiles en violation du traité
mais ce traité concerne particulièrement
l'europe puisqu'il trouve son origine
dans la crise des euromissiles des
années 1970 à cette époque les russes
avaient mis en place des missiles à
porter intermédiaires pouvant atteindre
n'importe quelle capitale européenne et
les américains en réaction avait décidé
d'en faire autant si bien qu'il a fallu
attendre 1997 pour que ce signe un
accord bilatéral signé par ronald reagan
et mikhaïl gorbatchev et qui a permis de
supprimer cette catégorie domicile des
deux côtés autre inquiétude la divers
poutine a indiqué via un vice-ministre
que le traité de réduction des arsenaux
nucléaires qui arrive à terme en 2021 ne
pourrais très bien ne pas être reconduit
nous avons donc l'impression que
l'histoire bégaie et nous nous demandons
comment faire en sorte que l'on prenne
en considération ses erreurs du passé
nous y voyons aussi l'opportunité pour
l'europe est bien de s'exprimer
fortement de façon à ce que le contrôle
des armes nucléaires soit une réalité
à l'heure actuelle la défense européenne
prend de nombreuses initiatives
s'éparpillant projet space co fonds
européen de défense 21 mai - se montre
incapable de présenter des solutions à
la hauteur des menaces elles restent
désespérément dépendante des américains
l'europe de poteaux prendre ses
responsabilités à l'égard d'un allié qui
ne se montrent pas toujours fiable et
prévisible et à l'égard d'une russie qui
multiplie les coups de force pour
affirmer sa puissance
madame la ministre quelles initiatives
comprendre la france et ses alliés
européens pour éviter le risque d'une
nouvelle course aux armements nucléaires
merci de votre attention pour vous
répondre le faron l'état valable la
milice chargée des affaires européennes
madame l'oiseau vous avez la parole pour
remercier monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur guerriau vous l'avez dit
l'europe a été il y à peu l'un des
théâtres de la guerre froide des armes
nucléaires américaines et soviétiques
stationnée sur le sol européen et par
leurs portes et ne pouvait frapper que
l'europe c'est à ce péril qui est venu
mettre fin à la signature en 1987 du
traité sur les forces nucléaires
intermédiaires qui engage l élimination
de ces armes de notre continent
aujourd'hui ce traité remis en cause par
les russes qui violent les règles de ce
traité par les américains qui ont
annoncé qu'ils vont s'en retirer la
russie a immédiatement fait savoir
qu'elle voulait développer un nouveau
missile
nous sommes dans une situation
paradoxale
les européens ne font pas partie du
traité est fini mais c'est bien la
sécurité notre continent qu'il s'agit
nous sommes devant un risque de relance
de la course des armements mais aussi
devant un nouvel épisode d' attaque en
règle contre le multilatéralisme
alors que faut-il faire tout d'abord et
nous le faisons appelé la russie à
répondre aux demandes qui lui ont été
adressés et à remplir pleinement ses
engagements dans le même temps et vous
le rappeler il faut construire une
véritable autonomie stratégique
européenne
le roc de la défense a plus progressé en
deux ans quand six décennies
le fonds de défense le feu jörg rahn
défense est désormais en place
la coopération structurée permanente est
lancé elle rassemble 25 états nous avons
aussi besoin d'initiatives européennes
d'intervention que nous avons initié qui
permet de créer une culture stratégique
commune entre les européens les plus
capables et les plus volontaires prenons
garde de croire que les traités de
maîtrise des armements appartiendrait à
l'histoire et fred est passé dans le
contexte international incertain que
nous connaissons ils sont plus
indispensables que jamais nous appelons
ainsi la russie et les etats unis à
prolonger au delà de 2021
le traité new start sur les arsenaux
nucléaires et à négocier le traité
successeur si nous voulons éviter on
conclure régner la loi du plus fort au
péril de notre sécurité nous devons
continuer à veiller à la force de la loi
merci la parole est maintenant le pré
collègue roger karoutchi pour le groupe
l'est républicain
monsieur le président monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
un référendum le jour des élections
européennes
les pauvres élections européennes
n'avaient rien demandé et un référendum
pour répondre à des manifestants d'hier
et d'aujourd'hui qui disent trop
d'impôts trop de taxes passé pouvoir
d'achat une dépense publique à revoir
trop de contraintes réglementaires et on
envisage un référendum qui dit on va
parler du parlement trop de députés trop
de sénateurs trop de mandat ce qui n'est
pas exactement on peut pas le dire une
réponse sociale économique par rapport
aux demandes de la population
alors monsieur le premier ministre comme
je sais que vous êtes un homme de raison
est ce que tous ces fakes news doivent
être démentie est ce que c'est une vraie
piste du gouvernement vers quoi va-t-on
pour sortir du grand débat pour vous
répondre
la parole et madame le garde des sceaux
[Applaudissements]
1 allégis madame le garde des sceaux sur
merci monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur karoutchi depuis
quelques jours effectivement dans la
presse c'est évoqué l'idée d'un
référendum qui pourrait être organisée
au printemps pour tirer les conclusions
du grand débat national que le président
de la république a lancé la question que
vous posez donc me semble parfaitement
légitime puisque la constitution et vous
le savez prévoit dans son article 11 la
possibilité que le président de la
république puisse soumettre au
référendum un certain nombre de projets
de loi cette procédure de l'article 11 a
été utilisé huit fois depuis 1958 pour
trancher des questions importantes sur
l'avenir du pays le grand débat national
tel qu'il a été voulue par le président
de la république permette à nos
concitoyens de débattre de questions qui
sont importantes pour leur avenir
vous le savez elles ont trait à la
fiscalité elles ont trait à
l'organisation de l'état elles ont trait
à la démocratie et à la citoyenneté
elles ont trait également à la
transition écologique et au moment où
nous parlons
monsieur le sénateur il y a eu plus de
4000 réunion qui ont déjà eu lieu il y a
eu plus de 700000 contributions qui ont
déjà été déposés sur le site
je ne vois pas pourquoi vous sifflez ce
sont des chiffres réels c'est tout je
crois donc monsieur le sénateur qu'il
convient de laisser ces débats se
dérouler et vous le savez le président
de la république et le gouvernement sont
à l'écouté français j'ai moi même mais
oui mais oui j'ai moi même eu l'occasion
de me rendre dans une petite commune du
tarn à giroussens où les gens se
respectaient est évoqué dans le calme et
la fermeté ce qu'ils traçaient pour eux
les lignes directrices de leur avenir
je crois qu'une fois ce grand débat
achevée
il faudra en tirer les conséquences cela
a été clairement dit de manière précise
et concrète
il appartiendra alors au chef de l'état
et au chef du gouvernement de faire les
choix qui s'imposeront monsieur le
ministre
karoutchi je connais trop votre
engagement gaulliste et votre
attachement aux institutions de la vème
république
croire que le recours à un référendum
serait pour vous critiquable en soi mais
en tout cas font qu'au moment où nous
parlons
cette question n'est pas à l'ordre du
jour monsieur karoutchi
[Musique]
je vous rassure madame la ministre je
n'ai aucune appréhension par rapport à
un référendum
je pense que le président la république
on aurait davantage mais c'est pas le
sujet là le sujet madame la ministre
monsieur le premier ministre c'est que
les français ont le droit de savoir ce
qui est l'issue de ce grand débat si
vous voulez faire une réforme
constitutionnelle complète pas juste des
bricoles de l'article le 11 mai
l'utilisation de l'ue 89 une vraie
réforme vraie république transformée
n'hésitez pas il ya un parlement pour ça
vous savez la démocratie représentative
ça peut compter moi je veux bien
tous les grands débats mais j'ai entendu
le président la république dire ce qui
compte c'est quand même ceux qui ont été
élus et je vais vous dire monsieur le
premier ministre
348 sénateurs 577 députés
925 parlementaire 925 citoyens rien mais
925 parlementaires élus de manière
directe ou indirecte c'est la france la
parole
et maintenant
au président hervé marseille
à qui s'adressent les applaudissements
aussi
le leader
s'il vous plaît
monsieur le président je ne sais plus à
qui s'adressent ces ovation si c'est
maintenant karoutchi ou à moi même j'en
suis ému j'en suis ému
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre à mon tour je voudrais
évoquer les suites de ce qu'on appelle
le grand débat comme vient de le dire à
l'instant mon collègue et roger
karoutchi et madame belloubet dans sa
réponse le grand débat se poursuit nous
dit-on jusqu'au 15 mars
il faudra tirer les conclusions de ce
débat et le moment venu
le chef de l'état et le chef du
gouvernement devront discerner ce qui
apparaît dans les conclusions de ce
débat pour présenter des réponses sous
une forme ou sous une autre
effectivement auger karoutchi vient de
le rappeler il ya le parlement
le parlement il est fait pour ça et il
est disponible pour discuter des
réponses susceptibles d'être apportées à
tous ceux qui débattent aujourd'hui le
parlement il ne s'use que si l'on ne
s'en sert pas et donc qu'il est
indispensable
effectivement qu'on puisse présenter
devant l'assemblée nationale et le sénat
les propositions qui pourront être
portés par des textes législatifs
le chef de l'état et le chef du
gouvernement peuvent aussi utiliser une
autre voie comme le garde des sceaux
vient de le rappeler c'est prévu par la
constitution c'est légitime c'est la
voie du référendum
si c'était le cas il est clair que nous
ne souhaitons pas et je pense que nous
sommes nombreux ici à ne pas souhaiter
qu'une telle consultation populaire et
lieu le jour des élections européennes
on ne peut pas mélanger les choses
à l'évidence pour des raisons dont
chacun se souvient aujourd'hui nous
n'avons pas eu le débat appropriée à
l'occasion des élections présidentielles
on en mesure aujourd'hui les
conséquences
il est indispensable on puisse avoir un
vrai débat portant sur la construction
européenne
l'europe est en crise l'europe est
malade nous voyons jour après jour les
soubresauts attristant du bric site
on voit combien l'europe malheureusement
ne s'occupe pas de la taxation des gaves
ça on voit combien l'europe ne s'occupe
pas des problèmes migratoires on voit
combien leur autre que si on s'occupe
pas des problèmes auxquels les français
attendent des réponses c'est la raison
pour laquelle monsieur le premier
ministre nous souhaitons que la france
retrouve le rôle moteur qui doit être le
sien en europe et que nous puissions
avoir ce débat
évitons d'avoir si c'est le cas un
référendum le jour des élections
européennes
merci monsieur le président pour vous
répondre la parole et à monsieur le
premier ministre vous avez la parole
tous
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
président marseille sachant que vous
alliez poser une question qui allait
intervenir après celle de monsieur le
sénateur karoutchi je me suis dit qu'il
était utile conforme à l'usagé d'abord
évidemment de vous répondre et utile de
pouvoir par cette réponse apporter des
éléments qui peut-être pourront
rejoindre des éléments de
questionnements formulée par monsieur
karoutchi
[Musique]
et
com
monsieur le président marseille le grand
débat a commencé
et alors même qu'il a commencé et que
beaucoup s'interroger sur les formes
qu'il prendrait nous constatons que par
le nombre de réunions organisées par le
nombre de contributions qui ont été
produits directement par les français
nous constatons et je pense que c'est
plutôt une bonne nouvelle
une très grande appétence de nos
concitoyens à participer à ce débat
on peut toujours çà et là à dire telle
ou telle réunion ne ressemble pas à ce
que j'aurais souhaité mois mais il se
trouve qu'elles sont nombreuses qu'elles
interviennent dans des grandes villes ou
dans de toutes petites communes qu'elles
permettent à nos concitoyens de
s'exprimer je pense que c'est un moment
important je pense que c'est un moment
utile que quand c'est un moment
passionnant pour vous dire la vérité
beaucoup et notamment les responsables
politiques s'interrogent déjà alors que
l'exercice commence sur les points de
sortie que ce soit à la fois les
solutions où les instruments qui seront
mis en oeuvre pour arriver aux solutions
je comprends parfaitement cette
interrogation elle est évidemment très
légitime
je crois qu'il est objectivement trop
tôt pour y répondre
trop tôt pour y répondre sur le fond
parce que le débat n'a pas encore
produit tous ses effets et peut-être
trop tôt aussi pour y répondre de façon
définitive sur les instruments mais je
voudrais décider peut-être monsieur le
président marseille quelques pistes la
première chose qui me semble assez clair
c'est que je ne crois pas qu'un
instrument unique soit de nature à
traiter l'ensemble des questions qui
auront été évoquée pendant le grand
débat qu'est ce que je veux dire
il appartiendra au président de la
république de décider si oui ou non il
veut faire une utilisation l'article 11
peut-être souhaitera-t-il organisé est
posée aux français la question d'une
adoption direct de tel ou tel projet
c'est ton droit le plus strict et je
pense que chacun ici le respecte mais je
ne crois pas en tout état de cause qu'
un seul référendum quand bien même il
porterait sur plusieurs projets de loi
suffirait à traiter à intégrer
l'ensemble de ce qui est dit et si j'ose
dire mesdames et messieurs des sénateurs
de ce qui est dit et de ce qui n'est pas
dit car un certain nombre de choses sont
parfois peu évoqués dans ces débats mais
nous aurons l'occasion d'y revenir
il faut donc s'attendre à ce que soit
par le référendum soit par la discussion
législative naturel soit par d'autres
instruments
j'ai entendu les organisations
syndicales et patronales
j'ai entendu les associations d'élus
évoqué la possibilité sur certains
thèmes probablement pas surtout de
mettre en place des processus des
concertations des consultations dans
lesquels des formes sinon de consensus
au moins d'élaboration collective de
solutions pourraient intervenir
n'ayons pas peur de cette profusion
d'instruments je pense qu'elle est
exactement à la hauteur des attentes des
français
compte tenu de la diversité des sujets
j'entends enfin la remarque que vous
avez formulé qui va dans le sens de
celles que monsieur le sénateur avait
évoqué d'une au fond d'une forme de
désaccord sur l'idée d'organiser un
référendum
le jour du scrutin prévu pour les
européennes je l'entends j'en prends
acte
un certain nombre d'arguments dans ce
sens sont parfaitement légitimes vous
les avez formulées on pourrait dire
aussi que il y aurait quelque chose
peut-être de lure pour les services pour
les collectivités territoriales a
multiplié les consultations mais
j'entends parfaitement l'argument que
vous avez formulées il est parfaitement
entendable aujourd'hui monsieur le
président
rien n'est décidé je sais que nous
vivons dans un monde où dès lors qu'on
commence à réfléchir à une hypothèse
elle se transforme un manque ablement en
un fait puis en une vérité puis on peut
évoquer et je dirais même réfléchir et
consulter sur cette idée je crois que
c'est important et je vous rejoins
parfaitement monsieur le président
le scrutin qui interviendra le 26 mai
pour les européennes
ce sera un scrutin d'une importance
considérable absolument considérable
pour la construction européenne et pour
notre pays
il faut que le débat ait lieu il faut
que les gens disent clairement que les
responsables politiques que nos
concitoyens disent clairement ce qu'il
souhaite
s'agissant de la construction européenne
ce qu'ils veulent assumer s'agissant de
la construction européenne nous avons
tous à gagner à la clarté du débat en la
matière j'en suis intimement convaincu
et tout ce qui permettrait ou pardon
tout ce qui aurait pour effet de
remettre en cause la clarté du débat
serait probablement écartée c'est
d'autant plus vrai que référendum ou pas
sur le sénateur depuis très longtemps
les élections européennes sont le moment
où on parle finalement assez peu des
élections européennes
et beaucoup de questions politiques
nationales nous le savons tous nous
l'avons tous vécu et nous n'avons pas
envie que cela recommence merci la
parole est maintenant notre collègue
richard yung pour le groupe de la
république en marche ce président
messieurs les ministres
je vous propose de quitter les rives
souriante du grand débat pour aller vers
des choses moins souriante reliés à la
fiscalité et ma question va porter sur
le prélèvement à la source du porte sur
le prélèvement à la source puisque comme
vous savez il a été instaurée au 1er
janvier et qu'il est les premiers
bulletins de paie arrive dans les foyers
ans membre elle est donc intéressant de
regarder ce qui se passe ça n'est pas
une affaire nouvelle
le prélèvement à la source je me
souviens que nous en avons débattu il ya
au moins 2 ans en commission des
finances
assez longuement et que d'ailleurs la
majorité du sénat était vivement opposée
à cette technique là bon enfin
maintenant c'est en oeuvre et on doit on
doit on doit avancer
il ya bien sûr un syndrome de questions
qui se posent par rapport aux salariés
par rapport à l'employeur qui est celui
qui fait le prélèvement par rapport aux
chaînes de fonctionnement informatique
toutes ces questions là doivent être
regardés et je me réjouis de
l'accompagnement qui a été fait du
travail d'explications très important
qui a été fait sous toutes sous toutes
formes pour expliquer cette nouvelle
cette nouveauté
je rappelle aussi d'ailleurs que la
france est un des derniers pays au monde
à mettre en place
le prélèvement à la source qui existe
depuis 1920 dans beaucoup de pays et
depuis 1945 partout en europe il ya que
la suisse qui n'a pas le prélèvement à
la source
alors chaque à chacun en tirera les
coquins
chacun en tirera les conclusions qui
veut et donc ma question porte mais
seuls ministres
ma question porte sur le lait premier
les premières conclusions le premier
bilan que vous pouvez en tirer
oui oui vous pouvez s'il vous plaît
répond quand on fait des choses vous
crier quand on fait pas de choses vous
criez donc au fort on n'a pas tellement
un d'hésitation à avoir donc nangon le
ministre
quel bilan quel bilan vous tirez est ce
que le taux nous de ton moyen a été le
plus souvent utilisés s'il vous plaît
sont les perspectives
non monsieur le ministre vous aviez déjà
la réponse mais merci à monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
monsieur le scénario vous nous
interroger sur la mise en oeuvre du
prélèvement à la source et je vous
confirme que cette mise en oeuvre se
passe excellemment bien et il n'y a
aucun bug technique aucun bug systémique
et la décision prise par le premier
ministre en juillet 2010 est de reporter
l'application d'un nom nous a permis
avec gérald darmanin de régler un
certain nombre de questions concernant
les particuliers employeurs concernant
aussi le versement d'un acompte de 60 %
de crédit d'impôt cette réforme ne la
faisons d'abord pour les français
d'abord parce que ça nous permet
d'adapter l'impôt revenus de nos
concitoyens avec une véritable
contemporanéité
et c'est d'autant plus important que 7
millions de nos concitoyens connaissent
chaque année une variation de leurs
revenus d'au moins 30% et ainsi nous
pouvons faire en sorte qu'ils soient
assujettis de la manière la plus juste
qui soit nous la faisons aussi à nous la
faisons pardon en appelant l'ensemble de
nos concitoyens a déclaré
les changements de situation que ce soit
un mariage ou au contraire un divorce
une naissance une modification du foyer
fiscal
une modification substantielle des
revenus pour faire en sorte que sous
deux mois
leur taux puisse être vu adapté et ainsi
que l'impôt payé soit parfaitement
conforme à la réalité de leurs revenus
et puis la deuxième chose sur laquelle
je veux insister monsieur le sénateur
c'est que si cette réforme est faite
pour les français elle est faite par les
agents publics
quarante mille agents de la direction
générale des finances publiques ont été
formés à cet effet sur les plus de 100
mille agents que compte cette direction
nous avons plus de 1000 agents qui ont
été mobilisés pour répondre à de
nombreux appels téléphoniques et nous
avons accueilli à peu près cent dix
mille personnes le premier jour du mois
de janvier dans 1500 lieu d'accueil des
perceptions sur l'ensemble du territoire
c'est une réussite technique c'est aussi
la réussite que l'on doit aux agents
le premier jour ce sont 500 mille
personnes contribuables qui d'une
manière ou d'une autre ont contracté
services fiscaux depuis le début du mois
de janvier nous avons modifié le taux de
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
contribuables pour mieux tenir compte de
la réalité de leurs revenus
nous avons fait en sorte que cette
réforme fonctionne bien et qu'elle
fonctionne aussi avec les collecteurs
les entreprises qui peuvent constater
aujourd'hui que la mise en place se fait
dans de bonnes conditions et un coût
bien moins important qu'est ce qu'elle
pouvait craindre
merci la parole est à notre collègue
véronique guillotin pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
vous avez la parole monsieur le
président chers collègues ma question
était adressée à madame la ministre des
solidarités de la santé alors que la
consommation de tabac baisse globalement
dans notre pays certains territoires
demeure malheureusement en marge de
cette dynamique positive
si les causes sont assurément
multifactorielles on fume davantage en
situation socio économique défavorable
l'une des explications est aussi
géographique en effet les quatre régions
où l'on retrouve le plus de fumeurs pas
ko de france occitanie et grand est sont
proches des pays où le tabac est moins
cher avec un paquet de référence à 5
euros 40 le luxembourg attire les
fumeurs du grand est et du nord lorrain
en quête de cigarettes à moindre coût et
notamment ceux effectivement du nord
lorrain où les taux d'incidence du
cancer du poumon sont déjà
significativement plus élevé que la
moyenne nationale d'après le récit une
récente étude de santé publique france
département frontalier de la région
présentent les situations les plus
préoccupantes
et pour cause l'augmentation du prix du
tabac en france mesure que j'ai soutenu
et qui a fait la preuve de son
efficacité a malheureusement encore une
fois renforcé ce différentiel entre les
zones transfrontalières et le reste du
territoire
face à ce constat la région gratte est à
lancer un programme de lutte contre le
tabac en effet cibler les publics les
plus à risque doit en effet être au
coeur de toutes les politiques de
prévention et d'accompagnement
néanmoins la forte attractivité de nos
voisins doit absolument être prises en
considération par le gouvernement pour
chaque action entreprise sous peine de
voir se renforcer les inégalités
territoriales en
matière de santé le tabac restant de
loin le premier facteur de risque des
cancers évitables en france je souhaite
savoir monsieur le ministre
quelle action vous entendrez mettre en
oeuvre à l'échelle nationale mais aussi
quelles initiatives
vous entendrez prendre à l'échelle
européenne afin de corriger les
conséquences de ces trop grande
disparité pour vous répondre la parole
et au secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre de l'action des comptes publics
me suis dit stop
je vais la mer roll merci mesdames le
président monsieur pardonnez moi merci
monsieur le président et madame la
sénatrice
vous avez eu raison madame la sénatrice
de poser d'emblée votre question agnès
buzyn car c'est aussi une manière de
souligner l'implication de madame la
ministre de la santé sur la lutte contre
le tabac et ses conséquences sur la
santé publique
mais le font d'autres questions
concernent essentiellement l'impact du
trafic de tabac et parfois même de la
contrebande en matière d'action publique
et vous nous interroger sur les actions
que mène le gouvernement pour diminuer
les trafics de tabac dans les zones
frontalières
nous avons pris un certain nombre de
dispositions notamment à l'occasion de
l'adoption de la loi de lutte contre la
fraude
nous avons notamment abaissé de 10 à
quatre le nombre de cartouches qui
peuvent être importées d'un pays de
l'union européenne pour faire en sorte
qu'au delà de 4 il y à une présomption
de contrebande permettant à nos
douaniers de pouvoir sanctionner celles
et ceux qui se livrent à ce trafic de
proximité
nous avons aussi fait en sorte de
doubler les amendes pour trafics
frontaliers en matière de trafic de
tabac en passant la demande maximale de
2500 à 5000 euros afin de dissuader les
trafics que vous pointez au delà de cela
nos services sont mobilisés de manière
massive depuis trois ans ce sont 1500
tonnes de tabac qui ont été saisis et
peut prendre peut être un exemple que
vous connaissez bien le 27 septembre à
saint-avold
c'est une tonne de tabac qui ont été
saisis à l'occasion d'un contrôle
inopiné
nous développons de nouvelles techniques
de ciblage vous faire en sorte d'un
d'agir avant le dédouanement et nous
contrôlons aussi de plus en plus souvent
des lieux de vente ou de trafics situées
au delà des frontières mais dont on sait
qu'ils sont propices à cette
consommation de tabac
enfin nous avons ouvert des discussions
avec nos partenaires européens
d'abord pour revoir la directive de 2011
qui fixe les minima fiscaux en matière
de tabac de manière à aller vers une
harmonisation fiscale que vous appelez
de vos voeux
vous avez aussi dit combien vous
souhaitiez qu'il y ait plus d'action au
niveau européen sur les quantités de
cabanes un portable c'est ce que nous
voulons aussi modifié puisque la
directive de 2018 fixe des limites
indicative
alors que nous souhaiterions qu'elles
soient prescriptive enfin madame la
sénatrice je dois préciser que ce
travail de lutte contre le tabac y
compris par le relèvement des prix que
vous avez cités nous ne menons bien
évidemment en veillant à être en
parfaite collaboration avec les
buralistes de manière à ne pas mettre en
danger leur activité
pas même le cas pour quelques secondes
oui merci monsieur le ministre mais en
fait la réponse me convient qu'à moitié
ce n'était pas une question de
renforcement de contrôle des fraudes
c'était bien une question sentais que je
voulais poser aujourd'hui est considéré
qu'il était important au-delà du tabac
de prendre la santé transfrontalière
dans sa globalité
que ce soit sur les ressources humaines
que ce soit sur la prévention et sur
l'accès aux soins
donc effectivement j'aurais à la reposer
à madame la ministre de la santé merci
merci la parent légal 1,3 collègue
pierre laurent pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologistes avaient
la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres ma question
porte également sur le débat national et
plus précisément sur les conditions
d'exercice du pluralisme dans ce débat
politique et médiatique déjà voulait
restreindre la liberté de manifester
ensuite la liberté de la presse est mise
à mal comme on l'a vu avec la lamentable
tentative de perquisitions à mediapart
hier ou avec la situation l'humanité qui
appelle la plus grande solidarité
mais précisément sur le débat national
ce débat est censé donner
prioritairement la parole aux français
c'est pour ça qu'il a été organisée et
il ya des centaines de milliers de
français qui s'engage qui s'empare de ce
débat comme vous l'avez dit mais force
est de constater qu'en même temps s'il
est impossible de mettre le couvercle
sur la marmite qui bout de la parole des
français
la part du lion médiatique elle elle est
taillée pour le
résidents de la république et pour lui
seul avec des shows présidentielle qui
sont rentrés retransmis intégralement
des shows dans lequel ils nous répondent
d'ailleurs je le remarque jamais
positivement aux demandes exprimées mais
par contre il continue de plaider sa
politique la question est donc posée
est-ce qu'on assiste à un grand débat
national appartenant à la parole des
français
ou est-ce qu'on assiste à une campagne
présidentielle de rattrapage dans
laquelle il n'y aurait cette fois qu'un
seul candidat
en matière de temps de parole je pense
que les compteurs du csa doivent
exploser il serait d'ailleurs
intéressant que les chiffres soient
publiées au fil du débat et pas dans
trois mois et rien ne s'arrangera je
veux le précisait avec l'élection
européenne puisque la loi vous avez fait
voter va répartir les temps de parole de
manière scandaleusement inégale donc je
demande ma question est la suivante
quelle mesure comprendre le gouvernement
et les garants du débat pour assurer
d'ici le terme de ce débat et ensuite
une égalité d'accès aux temps de parole
politique et médiatique ce qui est loin
d'être le cas aujourd'hui
la parole est à madame la secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre d'état
ministre de la transition écologique en
avoir vent monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur pierre laurent ce
débat ce grand débat c'est bien le grand
débat des français
4000 réunion qui sont déjà organisés ou
en cours qui vont avoir lieu
sept cent mille contribution sur la
plateforme
parmi ces 4000 réunion une dizaine une
quinzaine peut être une vingtaine dans
lesquels on trouve un membre du
gouvernement ou le président de la
république on voit bien que la
la grande majorité la quasi intégralité
des réunions se passent entre les
français les médias comme vous le savez
sont libres en france et nous nous en
réjouissons et tout ceci sera sous le
contrôle du csa nous sommes en relation
régulière avec les garants nous sommes
en relation régulière avec les cinq gars
ans et observateurs qui ont été nommés
par le président de l'assemblée
nationale par le président du sénat par
le président du conseil économique
social et environnemental et par le
gouvernement ces cinq gars en nous aide
à respecter les principes que nous nous
sommes fixés principe de transparence la
totalité des contributions sera rendue
publique ou mises en ligne sur le site
du grand débat principe d'exhaustivité
dans la prise en compte des
contributions toutes les contributions
seront analysés traités et restituer ce
débat est libre ce débat est une
opportunité ce débat nous permettra de
prendre les décisions qui s'imposent
sous le contrôle du président et du
premier ministre
merci la parole est à monsieur cabanel
pour le groupe socialiste et républicain
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président à monsieur le ministre fait
nos la loi dite et galim que nous avions
examiné l'année dernière prétend
améliorer le revenu des agriculteurs en
imposant une plus juste rémunération
son encre est à peine sèche pourtant les
ordonnances qu'elle vous a autorisé à
rédiger suscite de vives inquiétudes
dans le milieu agricole notamment chez
les trois quarts des agriculteurs qui
sont membres d'une coopérative
ils craignent une remise en cause du
statut coopératif en effet aux
ordonnances vos ordonnances à ces
minerais les coopératives des
entreprises commerciales pour le calcul
de prix d'achat aux agriculteurs ce prix
et c'est tout l'objet de la loi et galim
ne doit pas être abusivement bas au
regard des indicateurs a précisé
monsieur le ministre il faut comparer
que ce qui est comparable
la coopérative et la continuité de
l'exploitation et non une entreprise
commerciale
en effet l'inquiétude dont je me fais la
voix vient de ce que la notion de prix
sera appliquée par votre ordonnance aux
relations entre la coopérative
d'adhérents or la coopérative jusqu'à
maintenant n'achète pas nos produits
mais le vent aux entreprises
commerciales
c'est aussi pour cela que le médiateur
de la coopération agricole ne doit pas
être remplacé par un médiateur de la
relation commerciale
certes il peut y avoir des abus d'un
certaines grosses coopératives de la
gouvernance et à s'éloigner des
adhérents il faut évidemment les
corriger mais pas au prix d'une remise
en cause de la singularité du modèle
coopératif qui est fondée sur l'humain
et la solidarité beaucoup
d'exploitations sont de taille modeste
notament en occitanie comme le soufre
mon collègue du geiq fera montaugé que
j'ai le plaisir associé à cette question
elles sont fragiles elles font vivre les
territoires grâce au modèle coopératif
qui est un outil performant pour une
agriculture saine et de qualité
certains pensent qu'à terme l'objectif
de bercy serait de parvenir à fiscalité
à fiscaliser pardon le chiffre
d'affaires des coopératives
ce qui reviendrait à taxer deux fois les
coopérateurs monsieur le ministre nous
connaissons votre attachement à
l'agriculture nos agriculteurs mais il
ne faut pas seulement les défendre
contre les critiques mais aussi contre
les logiques purement économique qui
leur sont défavorables
alors ma question est simple quelles
preuves dessous
vos ordonnances apporteront elles à
notre modèle coopérative agricole
la parole est aux mines est chargé des
relations avec le parlement
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur cabanel je voulais vous
remercier de votre question est d'abord
excusé le ministre didier guillaume qui
est retenu en lozère pour le congrès
national de la fédération bovine
vous nous avez interrogé sur l'
ordonnance en cours de rédaction
relatives à la coopération agricole et
j'aurais d'abord replacer cette
ordonnance dans son contexte que vous
avez rappelé en partie d'ailleurs celui
de la volonté au travers de la tête du
texte de loi et galim de à la suite des
états généraux de l'alimentation et tout
particulièrement avec les représentants
des coopératives qui se sont mis
d'accord pour mettre en place des outils
permettant de donner une juste
rémunération aux agriculteurs
c'est dans ce cadre que l'instauration
du prix anormalement bas et vous l'avez
rappelé réclamée par l'ensemble de la
profession en est un maillon essentiel
ce contexte doit permettre de pouvoir
répondre clairement à votre
interrogation qui semble laisser
entendre que le gouvernement en tout cas
c'est l' inquiétude que vous aviez que
le gouvernement voudrait en réalité
mettre fin au modèle coopératif et ce
n'est pas du tout le cas
le gouvernement soutient fortement le
modèle coopératif qui est un modèle
comme vous l'avez rappelé de solidarité
de création et de juste répartition de
la valeur ajoutée entre les coopérateurs
de mise en valeur de tous les
territoires
même si comme toutes les organisations
ce modèle mérite d'être amélioré
les services du ministère de
l'agriculture travail en étroit
partenariat avec les représentants dix
coopératives y compris sur la rédaction
de cette ordonnance
le prix abusivement bas effectivement
par nature et par construction une
notion juridique qui peut rentrer en
contradiction avec la construction d'un
prix coopérative c'est pourquoi l'
ordonnance veille à préserver le modèle
coopératif en maintenant dans le code
rural est pas dans le code du commerce
est ce n'est pas la moindre des choses
la notion de prix abusivement bas et en
instituant le recours aux conseils à la
coopération agricole ou au médiateur de
la coopération agricole en cas de pré
litige est pas au médiateur des
relations commerciales
nous voulons maintenir l'excellence de
l'agriculture française et le modèle
coopératif qui comporte effectivement
qui compte trois quarts des agriculteurs
et en constitue l'un des fers de lance
et qui est pour nous un modèle d'avenir
je vous remercie
il a parlé à notre collègue claudine
thomas pour le groupe l'est républicain
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur gérald darmanin ministre
actions et des comptes publics suite à
l'action
l annonce faite par le gouvernement de
réduire les niches fiscales en diminuant
le plafond gobe global de ces dernières
moins imposant des conditions de
ressources pour en bénéficier a faim dit
vous qu'elle profite aux classes
moyennes plutôt qu aux plus aisés la
fiscalité française est un objet de
curiosité qui amène la france au plus
grand au plus au 1er rang des prix des
pays est européens dont l'impôt est le
plus lourd les deux ans que veut est
passé à bercy n'y ont rien changé
ce sont ces fameuses niches fiscales qui
permettent une bouffée d'oxygène aux
contribuables écrasé par l'impôt
aujourd'hui la crise des gilet jaune et
le besoin de ressources supplémentaires
conduit votre gouvernement a raboté ces
niches
l'objectif l'objectif étant de montrer
du doigt ces contribuables qui
bénéficient de niches fiscales et par là
même de les désigner comme des
privilégiés
soudain ces mécanismes dont on vante l
utilité emploi à domicile dons aux
associations investissements dans la
transition énergétique n'aurait plus
aucune justification
monsieur le ministre clairement vous
gérer une crise politique née d'un
ras-le-bol fiscale en créant tout
bonnement une nouvelle hausse d'impôt
encore une mesure à l'encontre des
classes moyennes 14
quand allez vous cesser de matraques et
ces français qui travaillent payent des
impôts et assure la solidarité nationale
du show
je m'unis monsieur le président madame
la sénatrice vous nous interroger sur la
dépense fiscale et je me dois avant tout
des excuses et gérald darmanin nice de
l'action des comptes publics qui est
retenue cet après midi vous annoncer
dans votre question le fait que nous
aurions décidé de revenir sur un certain
nombre de niches fiscales il n'en est
rien aucune décision n'a été prise
par contre il est important et
intéressant d'ouvrir ce débat la dépense
fiscale peut être un bon levier pour
promouvoir des comportements vertueux
pour mener et inciter à tel ou tel
investissement sans matière d'emploi
sont en matière de diverses politiques
publiques cependant force est de
constater vous pouvez faire ce constat
avec nous que l'accumulation les niches
fiscales dans le temps a amené à un
démembrement de pans entiers de notre
fiscalité a mené à une perte de
lisibilité et vous avez souligné
vous-même que nous affichons parfois des
taux de prélèvement extrêmement élevé et
que dans ces cas là les niches fiscales
servent de soupape de décompression ce
qui nuit puces à l'illisibilité qu'à la
simplicité du système
et enfin il ya aussi un phénomène
d'optimisation avec une superposition
niche qui permet à tel ou tel
contribuable d'être particulièrement
avantagé même si nous pouvons noter que
depuis 2008 notamment l'initiative de
gilles carez et didier migaud
déplafonnement sont intervenus de
manière successive au bénéfice de ces
niches fiscales nous allons travailler à
ce sujet avec en tête deux impératifs
le premier impératif est de continuer ce
que nous faisons depuis le début c'est à
dire diminuer les prélèvements
obligatoires sur les ménages et en aucun
cas taxer les classes moyennes le
deuxième impératif vise à trouver plus
d'égalité car par exemple en matière
d'impôt sur le revenu
vous devez savoir et vous savez
certainement que 10 % des contribuables
les plus aisés bénéficient de 50 % des
14 milliards de niches propre au seul
impôt sur le revenu
tous les parlementaires sur tous les
bancs madame la sénatrice ont toujours
dit au fil des débats mme qu'il fallait
clarifier et simplifier le système des
niches fiscales et je livre à vous cette
citation que j'ai trouvé dans le journal
les échos du 9 janvier
quelqu'un disait dans les échos le 9
janvier il faut tout remettre à plat en
matière de fiscalité il ya 350 pondent
impôts et taxes des niches fiscales
partout et ça manque de lisibilité
celui qui disait cette phrase frappé au
coin du bon sens s'appelle laurent
wauquiez
mode homme quand dean thomas monsieur
mini ce que j'entends bien vos arguments
quelques chiffres sur l'action de votre
gouvernement malgré tout le déficit
commercial de la france devaient battre
un record en 2019 à hauteur de 65
milliards d'euros le déficit public qui
devrait être contenue sous la barre des
3% est annoncée à 3 3% en 2010 9 et le
taux de prélèvements obligatoires que
vous estimiez à 44,3 pour cent dans la
loi de programmation à tiendra à 45 % du
pib
pas de quoi pavoiser monsieur le
ministre la parole et comme je suis un
vrai gâteau là pour le groupe de la
république en bas merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à madame
frédéric vidal ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur de la recherche
et de l'innovation
madame la ministre dans un monde en
pleine transformation technologique
l'investissement dans la recherche
constitue plus que jamais un enjeu
capital pour notre pays
malgré une légère amélioration la france
qui avec les autres pays de l'union
européenne s'était fixé en 2020 un
objectif de recherche globale de 3% de
son pib
penney en 2017 à atteindre appelle les
2,2 pour cent
nous demeurons loin derrière l'allemagne
derrière les etats-unis et les pays
scandinaves aussi et même si aucun
chiffre précis n'a encore été avancée
l'annoncé il ya quatre jours par
monsieur le premier ministre d'une
future loi de programmation
pluriannuelle pour la recherche est déjà
en soi une excellente nouvelle
elle souligne la volonté de notre pays
de passer à la vitesse supérieure dans
ce domaine à l'horizon 2021 date 2021
qui sera aussi le début du prochain
cadre pluriannuel financiers européens
qui avec le plan europe 2020 va
accroître considérablement les moyens de
la recherche communautaire alors face au
leadership américain et à la montée en
puissance de la chine
la mise en oeuvre d'une politique
volontariste dans ce domaine
la france est aux côtés de l'union
européenne ne peut être que favorable au
renouveau de nos industries à la
compétitivité de notre économie
ainsi qu'un autre souveraineté numérique
madame la ministre
pourriez-vous aujourd'hui nous préciser
quelles seront les priorités de cette
programmation et comment seront elles
articulé avec les mesures du prochain
cas de purée agnel financier européen
2021 et 2027 et enfin et dans la phase
de concertation et de préparation de la
future loi qui va s'ouvrir
comment entendez vous mobiliser au mieux
la communauté scientifique les
industriels et l'ensemble de la
communauté nationale sur ce sujet je
vous remercie pour vos réponses la
parole est à madame la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur de la recherche
d'innovation madame vidal vous avez la
parole madame la ministre
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur gâteau là
effectivement vendredi dernier pour les
80 ans du cnrs le premier ministre a
souhaité annoncer cette future loi de
programmation pluriannuelle de la
recherche et ça faisait longtemps bien
longtemps trop longtemps même qu'un chef
de gouvernement n'avait pas souhaité
réaffirmer devant la communauté
scientifique la confiance que nous
portons à nos scientifiques à la fois
pour améliorer l'avenir de notre pays
mais aussi pour continuer à produire une
connaissance qui est à la base de toute
innovation source de croissance et
d'emploi la décision qui a été qui a été
annoncé est une décision qui est
d'importance puisque dans les 40
dernières années
seuls trois lois de programmation ont
été votés dans le cadre de la recherche
il s'agit de travailler sur trois axes
principaux et de sortir des principales
contradictions qui souvent nous ont
empêchés d'avancer sur les questions de
la recherche des oppositions stériles
entre la recherche publique et la
recherche privée partout dans le monde
on parle de recherche la compétition
stérile entre les financements
compétitifs et
les financement récurrent partout dans
le monde ce qui est important c'est de
soutenir le financement de la recherche
c'est pourquoi trois groupes de travail
vont être mis en place comprenant des
parlementaires des scientifiques des
chefs d'établissements des industriels
le premier nous permettra de définir
comment est-ce que l'on finance au mieux
les activités de recherche de base celle
des laboratoires et une recherche
compétitive de qualité qui ne signifie
pas l'exclusion d'excellents projets
comment est-ce que l'on retrouve une
attractivité des carrières scientifiques
et enfin comment est-ce que l'on
soutient la recherche partenariale
je crois que c'est très important que
nous remettions la recherche au coeur
des priorités car la recherche est au
coeur de notre avenir jour merci merci
la parole est à notre collègue andré
richard pour le groupe l'est républicain
vous avez la parole mon cher collègue
mais si monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre si le veut bien
ce premier ministre les conseils
départementaux du bas rhin et du haut
rhin ont voté hier la même délibération
demandant la création d'une nouvelle
collectivité territoriale qui va
s'appeler la collectivité européenne
d'alsace c'est un nouveau chapitre qui
s'ouvre celui de l'entrée dans un
processus législatif qui pourrait
conduire je l'espère à la renaissance de
la région alsace ce sont ceux ci aussi
des nouvelles questions qui se posent
quelles compétences seront en définitive
dévolues à cette collectivité
en effet dans l'état actuel une
connaissance le projet de loi qui doit
sans préciser les termes restent
largement insatisfaisant
non seulement il ne décline pas
entièrement les compétences figurant
dans la déclaration de matignon du mois
d'octobre dernier mais il ne dit rien de
celles qui pourraient être transférées
de la région grand est
je voudrais rappeler ici que 84 % puis
83% des alsaciens ont indiqué dans deux
sondages successifs vouloir retrouver
une collectivité régionale alsacienne de
plein exercice
pouvez vous monsieur le premier ministre
nous éclairer
mais mes chers collègues le choix des
alsaciens illustre une question plus
générale que les maires ont posé de
façon récurrente au président de la
république
ils en ont assez de la recentralisation
rampante ils en ont assez de des
contraintes ils veulent plus de liberté
de souplesse il souhaite que les
périmètres des collectivités ne soit
plus déconnectés des réalités
économiques sociales et culturelles des
territoires la loi notre ne satisfait
personne
porté par ce flot de contestation le
président de la république a infléchi
son discours il s'est dit prêt j'ouvre
les guillemets à rouvrir la loi notre le
président ouvre des perspectives floues
mais des perspectives tout de même la
démocratie participative peut parfois
être une réponse mais dans ce domaine de
la réforme territoriale
on doit pouvoir faire confiance à
démocratie représentative sur ses bancs
à plusieurs reprises nous avons alerté
sur la grogne des mères le sénat chambre
des territoires par excellence à des
propositions etes-vous prêts monsieur le
premier ministre à y prêter un vrai
intérêt et à engager avec notre
assemblée l'acte iii de la
décentralisation je vous remercie
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur vous m'interrogez
sur une question particulière pardon qui
porte sur le processus engagé dans le
rhin et dans le bas rhin pour la
constitution d'une nouvelle collectivité
territoriale et puis vous élargissez
votre question sur les limites du
dispositif issu de la loi no trait sur
les correctifs qui pourraient y être
apportées vous fait l'avocat ce faisant
de la démocratie représentative de
l'ecoute des élus je voudrais vous dire
que s'il ya un domaine dans lequel cette
préoccupation est partagée avec
le gouvernement c'est bien sûr la
question de l'alsace car que s'est-il
passé sur la question d'alsace nous
avons entendu l'expression par les
parlementaires par les élus locaux
singulièrement aussi par les présidents
des conseils départementaux de
l'insatisfaction qui prévalait sur
l'organisation telles qu'elles résultent
et de décisions qui avaient été prises
d'ailleurs bien avant la nomination de
ce gouvernement
ayant entendu ces interrogations ayant
d'emblée fixé une limite qui avait été
formulée par le président la république
pendant sa campagne de non remise en
cause des périmètres régionaux tels
qu'ils avaient été décidés
nous avons essayé de travailler dans la
plus grande intelligence possible avec
les élus locaux et avec les
parlementaires c'est d'ailleurs parce
que nous avons réussi à travailler dans
ces bonnes conditions je voudrais saluer
le remarquable travail effectué par
jacqueline gourault à cette occasion que
nous sommes arrivés à une déclaration
commune avec le président du conseil
régional avec les deux présidents des
conseils départementaux avec de très
nombreux parlementaires déclaration
commune signée à matignon qui a engagé
le processus marqué hier enfin qui s'est
poursuivie hier par le vote
il faut dire un mot sur les conditions
de savate monsieur le sénateur si on si
on regroupe les deux conseils
départementaux du haut-rhin et du
bas-rhin on a 80 conseillers
départementaux sur les 80 conseillers
départementaux 1074 est positif je crois
donc monsieur le sénateur qu'on peut
dire et je suis certain que vous allez
vous en réjouir que nous avons en la
matière écouter discuter permis à des
collectivités territoriales 2 s'entendre
et que ce processus va se poursuivre là
où il doit se poursuivre
c'est à dire au parlement le parlement à
l'occasion de se prononcer sur un très
bel exemple me semble-t-il de
coopération intelligente entre les élus
locaux les parlementaires et le
gouvernement
je ne dis pas que
tout est réglé par cette déclaration
commune et certains peut-être est-ce
votre cas vous l'avez dit vous-même
monsieur le sénateur voudrait aller plus
loin certains veulent aller beaucoup
moins loin
je pense que nous avons avancé et que
nous avons avancé en écoutant et en
inscrivant dans le dispositif juridique
quelque chose qui peut faire consensus
partant de cette méthode qui n'est pas
propre à l'alsace car nous l'avons
reproduite dans d'autres territoires
partant de cette méthode vous d'indiquer
qu' il convient de modifier ce que
parfois on appelle les inconvénients de
la loi notre parfois on dit les les
irritants de la loi notre il existe on
le sait bien vous les avez souvent
dénoncé sur ses bancs je les ai moi-même
dénoncer car je n'ai jamais été un grand
admirateur de l'ensemble des
dispositions de cette loi mais je sais
aussi pour l'avoir vécu et pour l'avoir
vécu en tant que chef de gouvernement
qu'il est simple de dire qu'il y a des
irritants dans la loi nôtre mais qu'elle
est un petit peu plus compliqué de les
corriger
car déséquilibres se sont dessinés car
des intérêts contradictoires s'exprime
parfois des intérêts contradictoires
entre collectivités territoriales et que
lorsqu'on modifie ses équilibres ses
habitudes dans certains endroits on
aboutit à un très bon résultat dans
d'autres ont défait quelque chose qui a
commencé à être construit et qui
fonctionne bien vous le savez c'est la
réalité c'est la complexité de la vie
politique et administrative française de
la vie territoriales j'attire donc votre
attention monsieur le sénateur sur le
fait que oui nous devons évidemment
corriger les fameuses irritant de la loi
notre améliorer les dispositions mais
tous vont le faire avec
avec un très grand soin de ne pas
satisfaire
un appétit de match retour au détriment
de ceux qui auraient pu se construire
dans de bonnes conditions
dans certains endroits c'est un
équilibre délicat il exigera beaucoup de
finesse et beaucoup de travail je suis
certain que le sénat le gouvernement
travailleront dans d'excellentes
conditions ensemble sur ce domaine
merci la parole est à notre collègue
marie pierre de la gontrie
pour le groupe socialiste et républicain
monsieur le président monsieur premier
ministre
notre pays traverse une période troublée
qui alerte sur la fragilité de notre
démocratie
pourtant depuis 18 mois vous en attaque
et les fondements constitutionnels le
bicamérisme tout d'abord nous sommes au
sénat que le président de la république
a mis en cause ouvertement dans sa
lettre aux français la liberté d'aller
et venir et le droit de manifester
désormais sous une chape préfectorale
par votre loi anticasseurs vous attaquez
également depuis des mois à la liberté
de l'information avec la loi sur le
secret des affaires
puis la loi sur les faits que news qui
fragilise le travail des journalistes
la protection des sources et les
lanceurs d'alerté
le président de la république voudrait
aujourd'hui créer des structures
subventionnées devant veiller à la
neutralité de l'information au parfum de
pravda ou d'horaires tfc mesure ces
déclarations ensemble font système et
doivent nous alerter
hier c'était une tentative de
perquisitions dans les locaux de
mediapart à laquelle nous avons assisté
inédite inquiétante parce qu'elle touche
à la protection des sources
cet événement éclaire d'un jour édifiant
votre attention particulière à la
nomination de procureur de paris et
votre refus de l'indépendance du parquet
monsieur le premier ministre votre
majorité joue un jeu dangereux mais on
ne joue pas avec les libertés publiques
le paysage démocratique qui se dessine
sous nos yeux inquiète y compris dans
les rangs de votre majorité
il suffit de voir le score du vote sur
la loi anti-casseurs monsieur le premier
ministre quand allez vous cesser de
fragiliser nos libertés fondamentales
pour vous répondre la parole et monsieur
le président mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs de la masia
matrice de la gontrie
je vous ai écoutés évidemment avec
beaucoup d'attention mais je ne partage
pas l'analyse que vous faites de ce que
vous appelez un système je reprends vos
propres mots un système portant atteinte
à la liberté d'expression et au respect
des sources
je voudrais d'abord vous dire que en
tant que garde des sceaux et vous le
savez il ne m'appartient pas de
commenter des procédures judiciaires
je m'y astreins de manière extrêmement
strictes précisément parce que je suis
attachée à l'indépendance de la justice
et au respect des lois et vous le savez
ces lois m'interdise d'intervenir dans
les affaires individuelles je souhaitais
ici vous le rappeler je vais donc par
rapport à la sphère que vous évoquez
vous donner quelques éléments qui ont
été rendus publics
le parquet de paris vous le savez a
ouvert une enquête préliminaire portant
sur des infractions d'atteinte à la vie
privée
deux magistrats de ce parquet se sont
donc rendus au journal mediapart pour se
faire remettre les enregistrements
sonores de conversation qui serait
intervenu entre messieurs benalla écrase
les magistrats agissait je tiens à le
préciser ici dans le cadre non coercitif
de l' enquête préliminaire et il ne
pouvait procéder à une saisie sans
l'assentiment du représentant légal de
l'entreprise de presse mediapart a dans
un premier temps refusé de remettre ces
enregistrements puis ensuite les a
donnés à la justice ce qui a permis et
ce qui permettra de faire toute la
lumière sur cette affaire
madame la sénatrice je voudrais ici vous
redire que je suis attachée comme tout
le gouvernement et à la liberté de la
presse et à la protection du secret des
sources des journalistes
car je considère que ce sont les pierres
angulaires de notre démocratie
je suis également très attaché
à ce que la justice ne fasse pas l'objet
d'un talent d'incessantes qui paralyse
son fonctionnement
c'est je crois aussi un élément
indispensable du fonctionnement dans la
sérénité de la justice
c'est en tout cas ma conception de la
justice celle que partagent ce
gouvernement et je puis vous assurer que
je suis tout à fait en clean et disposer
et volontaires pour continuer en ce sens
madame de la gontrie d'abord dire mon
regret que le premier ministre n'ait pas
souhaité sur un sujet qui va bien au
delà des compétences de la garde des
sceaux s'exprimer à l'instant car je ne
vous ai pas demandé de vous exprimer sur
une affaire judiciaire même si madame la
garde des sceaux ayant commis une
tribune au mois de septembre afin de
tenter que la commission d' enquête du
sénat auditionne pas monsieur benalla je
pense que quand ce qu'il qu'en ce qui
concerne la séparation des pouvoirs
vous avez une conception qui est assez
variable je dirais simplement madame la
garde des sceaux
une phrase que je vous suggère de
méditer car elle est de vous tout
privautés prises avec les principes
essentiels de notre république ne peut
que contribuer au discrédit de l'action
publique
voilà madame ce que nous vous demandons
est ce que nous demandons à votre
gouvernement
merci la parole est maintenant on va la
présidente valérie létard pour le groupe
de l'union centriste j'avais la parole
madame la présidente
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues mesdames et messieurs les
ministres ma question s'adresse à madame
la ministre agnès buzyn et à monsieur le
secrétaire d'état adrien taquet en
charge la santé de la solidarité
le protoxyde d'azoté de vue le prg le
troisième produit psychoactif le plus
consommé chez les étudiants français
selon une récente étude de la mutuelle
ce maire est de plus en plus
régulièrement
c'est le cas dans de nombreuses villes
dans le nord par exemple seuls des
espaces publics est aujourd'hui jonché
de ces capsules grise de bâle ont éclaté
qui laisse à penser d'une véritable
banalisation de l'usagé du protoxyde
d'azoté par le détournement de son usage
conventionnel que ce soit par le biais
de cac de cartouches de gaz pour siphon
à chantilly ou deux bombes
dicale dédié aux anesthésies nouvelles
drogues tendance et récréative le
protoxyde d'azoté gaz hilarant fait donc
fureur chez les jeunes avec une
véritable dépendance à l'effet
euphorisant et ce d'autant plus qu'il
est en vente libre
un coût très modique et sans restriction
aucun visuel ou pictogramme sur
l'emballage une alerte sur les dangers
d'inhalation de ce produit bénéficions
d'une réputation de gaz récréatif non
addictif de drogue bon marché ayant une
hausse et vie nocivité négligeable ce
produit a donc tout pour plaire pourtant
ces dangers sont bien réels le protoxyde
d'azoté n'étant pas métaboliser par
l'organisme ces utilisateurs se sentent
souvent parfaitement normaux dans les
deux minutes qui suivent l'inhalation ce
qui les conduit à poursuivre leur
consommation mais vertiges maux de tête
vision floue malaise crise de panique
problèmes cardiaques peuvent survenir
la consommation excessive de ce produit
à des effets graves sur la santé et a
déjà fait de nombreuses victimes en
angleterre puisque entre 2006 et 2012 ce
sont dix-sept personnes qui en sont
décédées deux cas déjà connus en france
l'observatoire des drogues et de la
toxicomanie souligne que son utilisation
prolongée à des doses élevées peut avoir
des effets graves et des séquelles pour
la moelle osseuse
le système nerveux entraînant des
risques de troubles respiratoires qui
madame la ministre
nécessite que nous prenions très
rapidement des dispositions quelles sont
elles
que comptez vous faire vous savez qu'il
y à des questions qui sont posées ici au
parlement à l'assemblée comme au sénat
des propositions de loi allez-vous agir
je vous remercie on vous répond ma
parole et secrétaire d'état auprès de la
ministre de la santé monsieur adrien
tact et si monsieur le président madame
la sénatrice fin et et moi de vous de
vous répondre car bien que nous faisons
le plaisir de sa présence madame là la
ministre des solidarités de la santé est
aujourd'hui la fun oui je vous remercie
pour votre question madame l'affairé ou
bien connaissance et conscience des
problèmes sanitaires qui ce faisant
votre territoire à cause de ses produits
depuis plusieurs mois et je comprends
votre malaise et parfois votre sentiment
d'impuissance le protoxyde d azote vous
l'avez rappelé est un gaz à usage
médical utilisé pour les anesthésies par
exemple mais aussi à usage commercial
notamment
vous l'avez évoqué dans les bombes à
chantilly pour sa finalité médicale
ce produit est déjà soumis à la
réglementation des produits stupéfiants
pour son usage commercial d'aérosols la
réglementation et celle des produits de
consommation courante
compte tenu de l' usage détourné ces
bruits de consommation courante
il nous apparaît vain de mettre fin à
ces pratiques produit par produit en
modifiant en modifiant la loi seuls des
approches de prévention globale auprès
des jeunes pourront nous semble-t-il
porté leurs fruits même si il faut bien
le reconnaître nous le reconnaissons
nous ne pourrons prétendre à éradiquer
complètement certaines certaines
pratiques de nos de nos jeunes sur
l'interdiction de vente aux mineurs qui
pourrait être une autre solution nous
comprenons le souhait partagé par
plusieurs partis parlementaires
d'interdire cette vente aux mineurs mais
cela nous semble malheureusement assez
peu efficace
tout d'abord ce que c'est l'inhalation
du produit qui n'a pas cette finalité
qui peut ce problème et non pas le
produit lui même
par ailleurs les intoxications graves ne
concerne pas les seules mineures mais
aussi vous le savez car c'est le cas je
pense dans votre territoire
également les jeunes adultes et les
étudiants et enfin nous savons tous
malheureusement les interdictions de
vente aux mineurs
saverne dans ce domaine quand comme
d'autres insuffisamment respectée au
final madame la sénatrice nous ne savons
la meilleure chose à faire est
probablement de mieux communiquer sur
les usages et les pratiques à risque
auprès des jeunes c'est tout l'enjeu de
faire plus de prévention dès le plus
jeune âge et vous savez à quel point la
prévention est au coeur de la politique
de ce ministère soyez convaincus que
nous sommes pleinement engagés pour
lutter à vos côtés au côté des élus de
tous les élus locaux contre ce phénomène
nous devons mettre en oeuvre les actions
les plus pertinentes et ses actions
passe sûrement en priorité par l'école
par les universités par les acteurs en
proximité des jeunes et aussi peut-être
par les étudiants du service sanitaire
dont vous savez qu ils sont 47 milles
depuis cette rentrée à être actif auprès
d'eux
de nos jeunes pop reconnaissant merci
merci monsieur pour les miss mesdames et
messieurs les ministres des prochaines
questions d'actualité auront lieu le 14
février à 15 heures
la séance est suspendue elle sera
reprise à 17h55 pour la suite de la
discussion du projet de loi relatif à la
croissance et la transformation des
entreprises la séance est suspendue
merci
et voilà pour ces questions d'actualité
du sénat au gouvernement
avec une question marquantes quelle
issue pour le grand débat national
alors que l'elysée ait réfléchi à l'idée
d'un référendum le 26 mai prochain le
même jour que les élections européennes
et sur cette question du référendum
le sénateur et l'ère roger karoutchi et
le président des sénateurs centristes
hervé marseille on dit ont défendu le
rôle des 925 parlementaire pour débattre
et voter les propositions qui sortiront
de ce grand débat national
alors le premier ministre edouard
philippe n'a fermé aucune porte il est
possible qu'il y ait un référendum
soumis directement au peuple français il
est aussi possible que qu'il ya une
conférence sociale avec les syndicats et
les différents partenaires sociaux mais
il est trop tôt pour prendre cette
décision a affirmé le premier ministre
et puis toujours à propos de ce grand
débat national le sénateur communiste
pierre laurent a évoqué les show
télévisuel d' emmanuel macron pendant
des heures sur les chaînes d'information
en continu selon pierre laurent cela va
à l'encontre de l'équité du temps de
parole politique notamment à l' approche
des élections européennes et celles
organisatrice de ce grand débat national
à emmanuelle wargon la secrétaire d'état
qui a répondu en défendant
l'indépendance de ce grand débat et sur
la question des temps de parole et bien
elle a renvoyé la balle dans le camp du
conseil supérieur de l'audiovisuel
merci beaucoup alexandre et la garde des
sceaux nicole belloubet a également été
interpellés lors de cette séance elle
est à votre micro antennes tranier oui
nicole belloubet effectivement il a été
question des perquisitions chez
mediapart lors de cette séance de
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
est ce qu'il ne faut pas une réelle
indépendance du parquet une réforme pour
cette indépendance du parquet quand on
voit à quel point il ya un climat de
suspicion un certain nombre de personnes
ont parlé d' instrumentalisation de la
justice
aujourd'hui alors je m'inscris
totalement en faux contre cette notion
d' instrumentalisation de la justice le
parquet est évidemment totalement
indépendant pour tout ce qui concerne
les affaires individuelles je ne donne
évidemment jamais aucune instruction
cela va de soi nous avons déjà eu
l'occasion de parts de cordon ombilical
entre l'homme et le singe village
arrêter de jeter la suspicion sur la
justice sur les magistrats
je le redis ici
et membre du parquet sont des magistrats
ils sont indépendants est ce que vous
comprenez l'émotion des sociétés de
journalistes une trentaine qui à propos
de cette perquisition hier chez
mediapart vous avez parlé tout à l'heure
de l'importance du secret des sources et
de la liberté absolument nous sommes là
pour protéger et la liberté de la presse
et le secret des sources je les dis ce
sont vraiment des aspects essentiels à
notre vie démocratique ce qui s'est
passé chez mediapart
ce sont à l'occasion d'une enquête
préliminaire
deux magistrats qui se sont présentés
qui ont demandé que leur soit remis des
enregistrements sonores présumé étant
ceux de messieurs benalla écrase mais
cela n'a pas été fait sur le moment
comme c'était possible et par la suite
ces enregistrements ont été remis la
vérité sera ainsi rendu possible
également dans l'actualité l'adoption à
l'instant de la proposition de loi anti
casseurs à l'assemblée nationale il y at
il un problème politique quand on le
voit qu'il ya eu 50 abstention dans le
groupe de la république en marche malgré
ses biens les modifications qui ont été
apportées par la commission des lois qui
doit être une loi d' équilibre comme le
conseil constitutionnel a déjà eu
l'occasion de le dire dans plusieurs
décisions qu'il a rendu la liberté de
manifester est une liberté fondamentale
qui découlent de différentes libertés
constitutionnellement garantis la
liberté de l'est de venir et la liberté
d'exprimer ses opinions mais cette
liberté peut faire l'objet d'un certain
nombre de limitations en raison de
troubles liés à l'ordre public
c'est donc ce souci d'équilibré sur
lequel nous devons être constamment vif
un problème politique pour vous je le
dis ici nous sommes dans la recherche
d'un équilibre qui doit être absolument
préserver
merci beaucoup une cale belloubet
d'avoir répondu à mes questions merci
beaucoup au tam pour cette réaction en
direct et il allait de doisneau en
région sur ce gâteau au bonjour bonjour
est sénatrice centriste de la mayenne
vice présidente de la commission exerce
social ici au cdh on va parler de ce
référendum puisque visiblement l'idée
même s'il n'est pas arrêté
fait son chemin est ce que vous vous
seriez favorable à un référendum pour
justement sortir par le haut de ce grand
débat alors l'idée fait son chemin mais
l'idée fait surtout des bas nous l'avons
vu
question concerne est ce cette question
cet après midi lors des questions au
gouvernement
et on voit bien que l'ensemble des
sénateurs globalement est plutôt opposés
parce que au vu des applaudissements à
l'applaudimètre je dirais que faisait le
référendum fernand le jour des élections
opposés au référendum le jour des
élections européennes et moi je pense
qu'effectivement ça brouille le débat
parce que la question posée à un
référendum forcément va susciter
l'intérêt des français puisqu'il doit
faire suite au grand débat donc répondre
un certain nombre de questions posées
par les français et du coup le débat sur
l'europe sera escamoté à mon avis on ne
parlera on parlera moins d'europe
or on a besoin de parler plus d'europe
aujourd'hui parce qu'il ya des questions
incontournables sur la défense sur les
migrations sur l'europe sociale et donc
ses grands déballages nous devrons les
avoirs et pour un président de la
république qui a été élu sur un projet
européen
moi je comprends pas que justement il
brouille les pistes avec un référendum
qui viendra totalement brouillé 7 ce
débat sur l'europe d'avoir plusieurs
questions dans ce référendum des
questions assez simple qui concerne à la
fois la vie institutionnelle et
parlementaires on voit mal comment
l'opposition va pouvoir faire campagne
contre s'était notamment
la limitation du nombre de
parlementaires qui est plutôt bien vue
dans l'opinion publique
sans doute mais un référendum en dehors
de la question des élections européennes
me semblait plus justifier en tout cas
là deux questions le même jour
ça me semble effectivement donner moins
d'importance au débat européen
et c'est donc quelque chose qu'il faut
éviter il faut éviter alors les
questions qui pourraient être posées
bien sûr que nous sommes prêts à y
travailler d'ailleurs en premier lieu au
parlement parce que il y à un débat qui
devrait se poursuivre pour une réforme
de la constitution c'est quand même au
parlement d'en débattre en tout premier
lieu et c'est d'ailleurs ce qui a été
rappelé par monsieur karoutchi ce qui ce
qui est très gênant dans cette
proposition de référendum
c'est que quelque part la question posée
vous savez très bien n'est pas forcément
n'a pas forcément la réponse à la
question parce que les électeurs souvent
répondent plutôt au président de la
république est venu sanctionner pour
contrôler exactement
et d'ailleurs il ya les
constitutionnalistes qui a écrit un
éditorial il ya quelques jours qu'ils
étaient fortes intéressant justement sur
ce référendum il existe un coup de poker
pour le président et un coup de poker il
a donc dit c'est un poker un homme et je
trouve qu'il avait a ses raisons parce
que on joue sa place est en fait nulle
personne répond vraiment à la question
quelles réponses à ces mouvements d'un
gilet jaune quel issue à ce grand débat
si ce n'est pas un référendum et les
chalets de doisneau et bien écoutez pour
avoir assisté à l'un de ces débats donc
en province je trouve qu'un certain
nombre de questions sont effectivement
posé mais ça permet aussi collectivement
de se frotter à l'exercice de la
démocratie parce que les idées des uns
ne sont pas forcément les idées des
autres et on voit bien que l'intérêt
général doit être construit tous
ensemble et je ne pense pas qu'un
référendum mais ma question multiples
répondra à l'ensemble de ses
propositions ou de ses revendications
qui sont pareils avoir une réponse forte
de l'exécutif
ça passera par une de nouvelles lois
salomon sans doute sans doute mais on a
aussi la possibilité d'en débattre lors
de loi proposé au parlement
et je pense que la démocratie c'est
aussi la démocratie représentative
c'est donc les élus de la république qui
peuvent en tout cas être les acteurs de
cette réponse pour les français qui
aujourd'hui montre dans les grands
débats un intérêt à parler ensemble
merci beaucoup elizabeth doit être venu
sur le plateau de public sénat c'est la
fin de cette émission merci à vous de
l'avoir suivi très bonne suite à des
programmes sur notre antenne
[Musique]